this is the only car in the world that I
know that has NASA technology in the
trunk
[Music]
hi I'm John Wilde a guy who works at GQ
and let's walk through just about all
the cool design features here in the
twenty20 McLaren G demon a central
selling point of the McLaren GT is that
you've got all the creature comforts of
a car that you can drive 300 miles in
while also having 200 plus mile per hour
top speed and 610 horsepower and all
that McLaren engineering at your
fingertips you can do anything you damn
well please
that's what $250,000 McLaren Engineering
gets used the legend of McLaren as best
I know it goes a little bit like this
he's a guy named Bruce McLaren he was
from New Zealand he liked to go fast you
like to win on the racetrack he founded
McLaren to build amazing race cars fast
forward to the 90s he made the f1
probably one of the most legendary super
cars ever built at the time it cost
about a million dollars it was the
fastest thing on four wheels that you
could buy I remember hearing legends
about the f1 that inside of the engine
bay they had lined it with gold because
that was the best heat reflectivity
material that they could find at the
time and so McLaren maker of amazing
supercars China type of person who owns
a McLaren GT is somebody who is into
something a little bit more esoteric
it's not a Ferrari it's not a
Lamborghini it's and in most cases it
can probably be one we're not going to
go there for the competition you
probably looking at Porsche 911 Turbo
mercedes-amg GT OD r8 at the brand new
Ferrari romo all those cars are GTS GT
as in McLaren GT the stands for grand
tourer or Gran Turismo if you like the
PlayStation and feel Italian means it's
designed to go very fast for long miles
it's not a hardcore race car
one of the things that McLaren did with
the design here is they really tried to
visually stretch the car when they're
trying to do this subtle vision of
elegance and it has this long flowing
line that starts at the back comes all
the way to the front that stretched out
feeling really kind of lends it a length
that just signifies visually that it's
poised and comfortable and just as
really gonna kind of like glide over the
road one thing I want to talk about
first is the paint which here is this
beautiful green they call it Viridian
green McLaren made three special colors
that they felt were a little bit more
subtle a little bit more classy a little
bit more elegant it's deep and it's
flecked and it's layered they also have
a blue and they have a copper McLaren
uses those three colors on its other
super cars but they're super bold but
they're like an electric orange Super
Bowl blue they're crazy bright green
here they made them low-key the kind of
thing that looks good at a like a four
star Michelin dinner three-star Michelin
they're how many stars the Michelin
people get I don't know I eat a lot of
burgers every McLaren has those that's
their signature Lambos got scissor doors
McLaren has a dihedral doors dihedral
that go up and out a little bit that
means you can park just about as tightly
as you want and still get out of the car
looking cool one key thing about
supercars is that it's really hard to
get in and out of them looking cool it's
not so bad if you know the trick and the
trick is always lead with your ass
that's the only way but first swing the
legs in and then you're in this kind of
looks like a normal bit of fabric that's
been kind of layered in here that trunk
is lined with a super fabric that they
could develop with NASA they needed
something that looked good but it also
is fricative they wanted to make sure
that when you threw something back there
and wasn't gonna slip slide around and
then possibly come smack you in the back
of the head I would say it's got a
bigger than usual trunk much bigger than
just about anything else you'll find on
the McLaren gives it a lot more space
but again it's not very deep you're
probably not gonna throw furniture in
there or anything like that
this is really you've probably got two
very nice Louboutin keep all bags you're
gonna throw on the back and if you're
going with anything else you're probably
shipping it ahead
so you can see all over this car there's
vents there's intakes that means a lot
of air is going in washing over a crazy
hot engine and coming out of it could be
as hot as 500 degrees these exhausts
kind of bent right here with the mesh or
for heat to come out of and that's
really important because at some point
given that this is a car you're gonna
travel with and probably have luggage in
you're gonna end up standing around this
area this is where all the heat comes
out of there's a bunch of mesh back here
and they have to do some very
interesting engineered things to keep
that heat from coming off and just
cooking you yes might want to come
around here this would be the handle
that you'd put your hands on to kind of
open and close this thing the problem is
all that hot engineer is coming right
out this way and so McClaren had to
actually think about how do they make
sure that hot engineer doesn't make this
thing get too hot it's hard and it's
blocked and where you see the holes back
here there's none back here that's
thinking McLaren GT has wider exhaust
this one behind me has $3,500 titanium
exhaust but that's a special option
these are some big badass supercar
exhausts but a lot of MacLaren's there
in the center that just kind of
signifies supercar in a lot of ways what
they did here is they put them out wide
because they care when you're standing
back here getting your luggage frankly
when the valet is standing back here
getting your luggage that if the car is
on it's going to be like blasting hot
air at your legs and even with like a
nice wide stance you can see you're
still not gonna get singed that much so
thank you McLaren engineers for not
burning off our leg hairs much
appreciated one of the things they do
now on every car is they hide a key we
like the bird somewhere inside the car
now I can't show you this one it is down
inside of this vent at the very bottom
the only people who will ever see it
will be the very very good technicians
who work on this car but rest assured
that it is down there
[Music]
the engine is a four liter twin-turbo v8
engine MacLaren's bread-and-butter is
their engines
they got 610 horsepower out of this one
it's actually the same engine that is in
their 720 kingslayer supercar and
they've made some tweaks to it it
doesn't put out quite as much power it's
like being on a train it'll just
accelerate smoothly as long as you've
got a straightaway feel like usually you
would be like right about here I don't
see a button that would actually let me
get the engine cover off trunks front
and back the buttons to make it go
faster hold on one second do you know
where how to get the we can huh
[Music]
the engine is just stuck under there
that's where it lives they work with
Pirelli to make specific tires for the
GT to make it quieter they actually
built in a system of kind of layers and
foam and what it does is it just cancels
out literally vibration and noise
because tires are actually where that
stuff starts if that stuff starts
vibrating in ways that you don't want it
to it reverberates throughout the entire
car particularly inside and it just
becomes annoying and grating so they
fixed that with science McLaren GT has
this spoiler shape kind of built into it
in the back is a brief on what they put
on their long tail cars at the top end
of their supercar range and what a
spoiler does on just about any car is it
creates downforce it literally pushes
down on that part of the car that's
particularly key in a McLaren where the
engines are already in the back and
you've got a bunch of weight that means
it just keeps it really planted at high
speeds feels really stable it feels like
it's not about to spin off into the
atmosphere if you decide to do more than
like 90 miles an hour this is like if
you took kind of a I and married it to
like shock absorbers they developed a
suspension that is controlled in a way
that actually starts to learn it starts
to kind of gauge what's happening with
the road and adjust the suspension
accordingly if it senses like very early
on that it's reading some tiny bumps
it's going to start adjusting the
suspension to handle those things
[Music]
another thing you can kind of see in
here that's super cool is the carbon
fiber tub that McLaren uses in just
about all its cars tub sounds like a not
very sexy word but is actually one of
the most amazing engineered pieces of
any car that McLaren makes it's made out
of carbon fiber for two reasons one it's
superlight
- it's super strong if say you get into
a crash with this thing because it goes
so damn fast it would maybe save you not
a lot going on in here which is kind of
rare for a supercar one of the things
mclaren likes to do and does really well
is actually keep things pretty simple
the leather inside they source a lot
from Scandinavia because there's fewer
mosquitoes up around there that means
the skin the actual literal cow skin is
that much more soft and unblemished
another option you can get is cashmere
on the interior that as you might
imagine cost a little bit to put on a
car of this stature but name it another
place you could put cashmere on your
supercar one of the really cool features
of the McLaren GT something that they
actually took from their top-of-the-line
720 and managed to make it even bigger
here in the GT is this sunroof system
it's not a sunroof in that it opens or
closes but what this thing can do is
gets more transparent or more opaque
depending on these controls it adjusts
using filaments that are embedded inside
the glass as you kind of go from lighter
to darker what's making those filaments
more aligned when there are more line
more light comes through when they're
not aligned things get darker and more
opaque when you turn the car off it
automatically becomes the darkest
setting possible
it's a tiny space Sun as you well know
would absolutely cook the interior this
thing so they made sure that no matter
what you do as soon as you turn the car
off gets as dark as possible
[Music]
I'll turn the car on couldn't show you
the engine but at least you can hear it
beautiful there's two dials here one
controls the responsiveness the handling
there's a little H for that and one
controls the powertrain there's a little
P for that both of those dials go from
comfort to sport to track so chill
pretty aggro I want to rip your face off
and win the checkered flag and just
absolutely dominate and I'm rich and
that's what I'm gonna do when you switch
the powertrain one from Comfort which is
where we're at right now on up a sport
or track you're gonna hear a little bit
of a difference so you hear that it's
subtle and that's just it actually kind
of letting you know that it's ready to
roll a lot of cars performance cars at
least can do that they've got a system
within their exhaust and let it get
louder a lot of them these days though
are actually making a fake exhaust noise
and running it through the speaker's
into the cabin they're literally faking
a badass engine noise but McLaren being
McLaren was like that's trash why would
we do that
we have an amazing car and an amazing
engine so it's stunning and I'm sorry
that I keep talking over it we should
just sit here and listen to it
I'm happy to see that there's actually
cupholders in here there's three which
is kind of baffling because there's only
two seats do we have any cups that I
could use what do we got we got a coffee
cup fits fairly easily in the main one
back here where the other two are that's
a little I wouldn't trust that one and
not even at all now I don't even know
what that would fit I guess that's maybe
like an espresso okay we got Pepsi it's
fine not at all in the second one and
yeah that's nope nothin there ah yes
beautiful amazing it's fine they're not
at all back there not at all there as
well so really it has three cupholders
but actually only one cup holder so I
revised that enthusiasm and surprised
into too bad for your passenger I guess
they've just got to have a Camelback or
something I don't know hold it in their
lap and hope you don't accelerate you
fast inside the cabin McLaren made sure
to use really solid tactile materials
one of the ones that they really focused
on was billet aluminum bi ll e t that's
when you take a solid chunk of aluminum
and just carve a shape out of it you'll
see it on the steering wheel on the
surround in the screen that's in the
console even on the vent knobs solid
aluminum even though it's heavier and
kind of ways to car down it keeps a
warmth and a smoothness and a tactility
that just makes you think this is a rich
car one of things we got here is the
infotainment Center one of the things I
like is that the HVAC controls heating
ventilation and air conditioning always
have a little guy that looks like it's
ready to race it's got a helmet on
they've got ambient lighting that you
can check out and kind of like tweak
inside the car and that's a lot of fun
because you can just kind of make it
whatever you want
you got six colors to choose from not a
ton but enough personally I like the red
in the blue the places you'll see them
are down in the footwell and then also
on this very cool strip of metal when
the lighting comes on there's a little
bit of transparency to the aluminum
that's really just showing off
it's a McLaren that took a xanax before
liftoff is what GT really is they made
something that's actually comfortable to
use everyday and that's kind of a big
deal for McLaren because their expertise
is in just making things that go faster
that destroy people that crush things
everything that went into it from the
paint scheme to the design of it it's
all built to make it more comfortable
for you to use every day
[Music]